the daytona 500 is one of the biggest
sports events of the year so get your
friends and family together and watch
the great American race with a Daytona
Day party right in your own home now to
make things extra special I've traded
the official data and add a party menu
and want to show you how to make two
delicious dishes let's get started now
the secret of a great slider has to be
their amazing but a pork look at this
baby this is a very cheap cut it looks
expensive but it's very cheap so the
secret behind this is making sure you
cook it low and slow now is to sort of
give it a really good rub and marinate
first off a really nice smoked paprika
brown sugar on top next to that sometime
flowers dry time is great and then some
minced garlic all you do now is just get
your hands in there and start rubbing
the secret here is to literally coat
this pork butt in all those spices
really starts to flavor
look there yeah that's a beautiful
incredible fragrance pork butt so get a
nice long roasting tray lightly oil it
from there get your onions just peel
them and slice them in half onions in
now that's what the pork butt sits on
okay from there get that up to temp
and then likely season those onions so
fresh thyme in again dry thyme is fine
we're trying to do now is make this
amazing sort of bed of this sweet can
lies onion that pork sits on throughout
the eight to ten hours
lift up your pork sit that on top of
your onions and then from there take
your stock this is the plain chicken
stock so you can use vegetable pot if
you wish and pour that over now
basically that's it before it goes into
the oven a nice seasoning on top stock
comes up to the boil and then Tim for
[Music]
plucking your ends and then literally
that is it and then from there into the
oven at 250 for a minimum of eight hours
right
[Music]
let's think about slaw first off the red
cabbage this is just shredded ultra
thinly we're going to use a sort of
really nice white cabbage and then the
carrots now again rather than slicing
them grate the carrots mix them up and
then from there just to sort of lighten
this up a little bit and make it a
little bit sort of zesty take your
lemons and get the zest of a lemon that
perfect sort of amount of acidity from
their lemon in and already just for the
zest and the lemon juice the whole
thing's fresh and now for the dressing
this is a really delicious like
buttermilk vinegar dressing with a touch
of honey in there now give that a really
good mix up that starts to formed a
delicious slider this buttermilk slaw
especially the lemon makes it nice and
light fresh an incredibly flavorsome
this is where the magic unfolds hmm
we'll just come a little bit closer and
have a look inside here mmm look at
those just the flavor will start slicing
the pork will make a shred it nice and
fine oh I'm gonna dip that in the juice
and then into the bowl first off the
slices are nice and thin lay them onto
the board and then from there literally
get the knife doing the work and look
okay
now the secret from there those onions
what we call a chef's dream you take the
onions and likewise hold them together
turn them over and literally slice we've
got this caramelized onion puree that's
running through that pork
you can't buy those onions in now for
putting these delicious pork butt
sliders together
gasps on slice the buns in half and just
toast them lightly this starts to sort
of almost protect the bun it stops it
from going soggy and look that's all I
want a nice toasted bun now we'll start
off with a little bit of Chipotle just
dab that on the bottom it's nice and
moist
now just from there take your slaw again
don't go crazy give it a good mix sit
that on top got flavor in going that
extra yard I'm toasting those buns makes
a massive difference let me tell you and
now for the magic the pork be generous
and literally sit that on top of the
slaw you've got those onions smell how
sweet they are is incredible and then
finally before we put the lid down on
that slider take your
Chipotle just sit down on top that is a
perfect race day treat finally take your
buns and let's sit them on top and push
that down a little bit so they don't
fall out they have to be the tastiest
pork sliders anywhere on race day good
luck and there we are these incredible
pork butt sliders and that completes
this incredible Daytona party menu with
the most amazing mac and cheese a
grilled romaine salad and the sweet
potato tater tots and of course this
wonderful flourless chocolate cake and
let's not forget a Daytona destroy a
cocktail all these recipes online this
will complete an amazing day good luck
and have a fantastic weekend